is it a reality or fantasy false or
fiction true or false
women have more influence than men on
whether a relationship will be connected
and fun or distant go ahead and think
about it true you got it that's what it
is Laura Doyle she goes on to say women
are keepers of the relationship and have
much power over the culture in the home
please comment on this well absolutely
this time we start the courtship really
men are asking women out so we have a
lot of power it's almost like you're
let's say you're the director of the
Broadway show you get to say okay this
dancer is in or that one's out we're
auditioning men for the role so that's a
very powerful position and then it
continues it as a relationship develops
we we are the gatekeepers for sex and
then it turns out that we also initiate
the most divorce some studies show that
says highest 90% among colleges you
educated women where the woman has
initiated the divorce the person is
willing to walk away and unfortunately
also has the most power in the
relationship and because men want to
make us happy you know I got thousands
of men in this question I'll say how
important is it to you that your wife
and is happy back let me ask you that
question let's just get on the table
right here how important is it to you
that's huge yeah across the board
it's a crazy you know everything that
you you have I mean we're going for it's
like the standard but you know you
obviously have exceptions to every rule
we're talking about the standard right
you know well it's like the most
important thing is everything you know
you have you had some oddball salt or
it's pretty now I've never once had
anyone say anything any man say anything
except in the UK they said it's
imperative so all over the world it
seems to be the same thing and so
because men just want to make us happy
we have we hold
if we make her so happy then he's happy
and we're happy and then the
relationship is happy and it kind of
stands to reason that only happy people
have happy relationship why she says why
isn't he then making me happy
I miss Laura Doyle you know you seem to
know it all why isn't he making me happy
that's a great question and that was see
I believe that my husband didn't care
about my penis have you had those
situations where someone will get a
little attitude and snippy with you oh
absolutely and rightly so you know I
think that's the great thing about the
intimacy skills it's like test em out
see if they work for you that's what I
did it first - I just started
experimenting in my marriage but my
husband can't make me happy for two
reasons one was that I was unplayable in
fact it's now someone asked him recently
like what's the number-one quality you
want in wife and he said please ability
he wanted to be able to please me and I
wasn't feasible no matter what he did I
found fault with it like he would clean
the kitchen and I go well what about you
didn't wipe off the counters so when are
you gonna do that right there wasn't
much appreciation and the other piece
was that he knew that I was not very
respectful
I didn't think very highly of my husband
I felt that I was a smarter when I had
this superiority complex I thought I got
I'm just a little I have a little more
common sense than he does and I'm just a
little better at practically everything
because I like having things my way and
I'm not proud to say that because and
through this journey I've gained some
humility I'm happy to say and I didn't
even understand why I would want that
before I didn't I didn't know why you
want to be humble and now I can
appreciate oh give me an example this
just happened we were getting ready for
our tax appointment and the previous tax
year we could put in new windows and air
conditioning and my husband's kind of
famous for like that's a tax deduction
you know noise like oh no and he's well
we make all of your videos here in the
house and the windows up to soundproof
the house and the air conditioning made
it so we can tape on hot days without
you
you know dripping with sweat
happens where we live down sometimes so
after he explained it I was like oh
maybe is I mean I don't know we brought
it to the CPA and I'll figure it out but
I don't always know I'm not the big
smartypants that I thought that I was
beautiful that really is I like what you
said you said unpleased well I mean I've
had people who say that look no matter
what I try there's no pleasing this
person so this is really profound let's
move on to number that was three right
how are you guys doing now okay